[Music]
hello and welcome to this the very first
episode of night city wire a brand new
series from us at CD Projekt RED where
we'll be talking about all things
cyberpunk 2077 for today's episode we'll
be starting with a brand new trailer one
of our developers will be joining us to
help unpack everything you're going to
see we'll have some news an announcement
about a secret collaboration we'll be
taking a look at some brain dansgame
play and welcoming back our developers
just to have a chat about everything
you're going to see but there is one
more thing media all over the world have
been getting hands-on with cyberpunk
2077 and when this episode finishes
you'll be able to go and check out
exactly what they thought so let's get
started
it is time to take a look at our brand
new trailer and after that I'll lead
quest as I know papal fasco will be
joining us because I've got a feeling
you're gonna have a few questions after
watching this so let's take a look
of this city of endless opportunity
ready to get your cherry popped
come on like any other it's bigger
I just hit another city legends are born
here in a chewy brownie here cos Dex on
the strings doubt that put cease and we
lose them but we are they just don't
know it yet
but if you got the cojones and you know
how to use them you could do damn near
anything unless you catch it all even
then you go out with a bang you can make
heaps mores motivations yo mr. V a
pleasure so what's the game Dex
we need to come out in one piece how
about we go over the plan there's this
prototype 10 biochip to be precise jobs
to plan esna belongs to a court arasaka
me Robbie some heavy hitters you can
blackmail me [ __ ]
how is have a war first rule of the
afterlife to cut king baby
it goes without saying we do this on the
hush
I deal in nobody not a one
sound simple enough
is it gonna be dangerous don't you worry
number one we're bulletproof like a
[ __ ] Poppins in there it stopped
digging nice [ __ ] meat you happy now
Jackie [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
six what the [ __ ]
gay miss could be and you who are you
[ __ ] so the trailer contains footage
from the game's prologue only but there
was an awful lot in it so Pavel why
don't you try and help us unpack
everything that we just saw oh yeah I
mean absolutely I can try so would you
have just seen it's only the prologue of
the game so the awesome stuff is only
happening in the first few quests what
the trailer show you who is really our
stage the night city you know this
gigantic city build of six completely
unique districts surrounded by the
seventh one that we call the badlands as
a player you are meeting Jackie Jackie
is your friend now they together are
trying to reach out for something that
is very precious they were trying to
reach out for this chip of immortality
this gateway to eternal life
Jackie introduces you to fixer Dexter
DeSean he's a very important person in a
social ladder of cyberpunk he is able to
provide the player with various jobs and
contracts to be able to gather money to
be able to modify their bodies push
themselves to the limits to put their
hands on a chip but as you can expect
not everything goes as planned and but
to to see it you will have to play the
game there are an awful lot of really
cool things in this trailer and there's
a few that I would just love to talk
about a little bit more for the people
at home so let's start with talking
about a gang called the MOX now we see a
few flashes of them in this trailer I
personally think they're really cool on
one of my favorites but can you give us
a little bit more information about them
oh yes so the box is one of the gangs
that player is going to interact with
throughout the game the box is the gang
that has been formed in 2076
after death of Elizabeth Borden she was
called Lizzie now she was an owner of a
brothel and former sex worker and she
was
protecting working guys and girls from
harassment from abuse and the gang is
really continuing her mission and as a
player you are going to interact with
that gang meet multiple different NPCs
and craft your own relationship with
them and understand what they are all
about so earlier on you did mention a
7th district a place called the badlands
now we saw a few shots of this in the
trailer but I'd love for you to give us
a bit more detail about the district
outside of the city walls okay so the
badlands is this like dead dried-out
space going around the whole night city
and as a player you'll be able to
traverse that space in your car and
motorcycle this is a space that is
inhabited by the nomads no matter living
in a different families and they're
traveling across that space in convoys
made out of the cars and motorcycles and
as a player you'll be able to traverse
an axis different type of open-world
content that has been prepared
specifically for you to that get that
awesome feel of the badlands as an area
in the trailer we also saw like a
completely metal creature now he didn't
look like he was from the Maelstrom gang
this looked like something else so this
other people at home who is this giant
metal monster okay so so the big dude
that was atom smasher he has been
introduced in a pen and paper in
cyberpunk 2020 by our senpai Mike bond
Smith atom smasher is a fully converted
cyborg he is who was always a loyalist
of Arisaka and time has changed and in
2077 he had to find his own space in
night city but to find out you have to
play the game in this trailer we do see
some flashes of a ripper doc call Victor
vector I think if people have watched
our previous gameplays they might
remember him but I'd really like for you
to give the people at home some more
information about what Ripper docks are
and how they'll be interacting with them
when they play cyberpunk so rip or dogs
in our game
they are surgeons they are like a
specific type of a job in the social
ladder of cyberpunk
they are accustomed and specialized in
replacing limps to the metal ones they
can basically update your body enhance
your body change you into this
walking war machine and as a player you
are going to move different kind of
Reaper dogs in the game craft your own
relationship with them some of them are
like important characters for a for a
story to that you will invest Eddie's
that you're gathering to turn your body
into this tool that allows you to
survive on the streets of night signal
pavel thank you so much for joining us I
know you'll be back later in the episode
because you're gonna be helping us to
analyze the brain dansgame play but
before that we do have some news to
share